I have heard that people at Google are extremely smart,
talented,
and very good with numbers.
I'm a neuroscientist.
I love to see for myself.
That's really true.
So I'd like to ask 10 people to come over here.
We're going to do a little competition and put this to a test,
please.
Otherwise,
I'm just going to take the first rows.
If nobody dares you guys here already doomed.
So five people over here,
five people over there,
three,
four.
Okay.
Five people.
That's five people.
Good to people here.
We need three more.
Okay.
Here's what we're gonna do.
Um,
we're going to work in two competing teams.
I'm going to start with the first team over here,
and you guys are not supposed to talk to each other.
You just watch them and white that they make a mistake,
okay?
I'm not as good with numbers,
so I need your guys' help.
If anybody makes a mistake,
led me know,
could you please form a circle and Natalia will be in the middle.
So all you have to do is to count to 100 okay?
Can we just give it a try?
One,
three,
four,
five,
six.
Okay.
You can count.
That's good.
So super smart.
Supposedly I would like to introduce three simple rules.
Okay.
The first one is called the evil number seven.
So don't say any number that has a seven and it's like 67 or [inaudible] 87 or
something like this.
Don't say any number where the multiple and where that is a multiple of seven
such as I'm 77 or 49 don't say any number where the two digits add up to seven
such as in 52 you guys are supposedly smart,
right?
So
when such a number comes up and it's your turn,
and let's take you more in the middle so that you're not confused as a
participant.
Great.
So when such a number comes up,
what you should be doing is instead of saying the number,
you swirl around your own access,
can you do it like this?
And when you're back here facing the others,
you clap your hand.
Can you do once?
And then the third rule is your team must reverse directions.
Okay?
We just try it quickly.
So you go first one.
No
[inaudible]
four five,
six and then you,
and then do your reverse directions.
Okay.
You got it.
Oh,
the rules clear.
Please watch them.
I'm not such a number person.
So ready,
set,
go.
One,
two,
three,
four,
five,
six,
10,
11,
12,
13.
Okay.
oh,
okay.
Let's give them an applause.
Just stay here for a moment.
Not,
don't talk down.
Outsmart me.
Don't make up any smarts.
Redditers please.
Let's see if you can do any better.
We've taken marina in the middle so you just hide here.
Okay.
Ready?
Set,
go to sweet.
[inaudible]
you can all go back to your seats again.
What did we just experience here?
Why was it so hard to count to 100 and why would that matter to you?
Right.
Who cares if they can come to 100 I will tell you why.
I will give you a closer look at how the brain works to understand what just
happened and also to help you understand how you can use that knowledge to
improve your performance.
Okay.
At any time,
feel free to interrupt me and to ask questions.
I love questions and I love to be challenged.
So if something is unclear or you have a little question,
just raise your hands and you will get a microphone and you can ask right away.
So don't wait to the very end.
I'm flexible.
So use the action,
the possibility to ask right away.
So if this is the head and you can see it from the side with the eyes here and
this is your brain,
there's a part of the brain called the pre frontal cortex,
Pfc.
That's the part of the brain that makes you successful.
That's the part of your brain that you use for complex decision making,
rational sinking planning perhaps with the future that toward your need in order
to be a high performing person.
Researchers found that already at age five you can see if children have well
developed prefrontal cortices.
And what they did is they made an experiment where they had people,
our children sit down in a chair,
in a laboratory setting and they said,
you can get one marshmallow now and they put it in front of them or you can wait
for 15 minutes and then you can get a second marshmallow if you manage to wait
for those 15 minutes.
Well then the research has left the room and left the kid alone with a
marshmallow for 15 minutes.
You would see some kids that would run for the marginal lunch,
just eat it,
get it over with.
Right.
And some others that would turn around ignore the marshmallow or put it under
the table so they didn't have to see it or play with it and throw it in the air.
Crazy things happened.
But what research has found that the kids that were able to wait for just 15
minutes to get a second marshmallow were the ones that were way more successful
later in life.
They had their earned more money,
they had better jobs that have better health,
they were happier overall.
So success in life is correlated with how well your prefrontal cortex is
functioning because it's your prefrontal cortex that helps you,
helps you to make executive decisions,
and it helps you to have executive control.
When we did this little experiment over here and I introduced the rules with the
evil number seven and the swirling around and not seeing the number and then
reversing directions,
this was a task aimed to test or to freak out your prefrontal cortex.
You had to use your prefrontal cortex to manage these different rules and to do
these calculations in your hat.
The problem is as we know,
the prefontal cortex sales very quickly,
right?
And we could all see it here.
Um,
so
we like to think of ourselves as rational beings.
We think that we're so smart and we are always in control of things and we're so
rational,
but that's not how our brains work.
But in order to be successful in life and in order to be innovative,
in order to create new ideas and to be high performing,
you will need your prefrontal cortex.
So I will show you today how you can improve your prefrontal cortex.
But before that I will show you which other brain areas always run over the
prefrontal cortex because it's a part of our brain that was only fully
developed.
Um,
you know,
at age 18 or 21 for you,
maybe some of you guys here don't even have a fully developed prefrontal cortex.
If I look at the audience,
it's a part of our brain that,
um,
is the newest from an evolutionary perspective.
And it's also the one that takes longest to grow.
So,
you know,
I have five kids at home under the age of six and they do crazy stuff and I
said,
stay relaxed because I know it's just that their prefrontal cortex is not
working fully yet.
So,
which are the brain parts run over the prefontal cortex.
There are many other areas that influence it.
But I'd like to highlight one today that we could see in our little exercise and
that really determines much of what's going on in our lives.
It's a part of lower brain called the Basal Ganglia.
What are the Basal Ganglia?
That's where your habits are stored.
That's where your mindsets are stored.
That's where your belief system is in.
So if you think that Brexit is a good idea or that voting for a certain
political parties,
a good idea that's probably stored in your basal Ganglia and your brain,
when you have lots of experience,
it goes into your basal Ganglia.
If you think about the the game we did
it aimed also at your basal Ganglia because what did you do that you learned at
age two or three or one
counting?
All of you know how to count and the better you know how to count,
the more it is represented in your Basal Ganglia.
And once it's something is in your Basal Ganglia,
you don't get rid of it anymore.
Once you know how to ride a bike or once you know how to count,
you can't unlearn it.
Once it's there,
you're stuck with it,
okay?
And it will overrule everything else in your brain.
So you need to be aware also of habits you create because they can be very
stubborn.
To illustrate this.
If you think about it,
the first time you learned how to drive a car,
maybe at your first driver's license,
that was really something that required a lot of attention.
You had to focus on the wheel.
You had to focus on pushing the brakes.
You have to focus on shifting gears.
There was a stop sign,
oh,
there's my driver.
Teachers is talking to me.
Oh,
what a distraction.
Right?
You're totally getting shivering.
This is because you drove with a part of the brain called the prefrontal cortex.
You had to use your prefrontal cortex for driving because he had to think of all
the rules and that's something you had to do consciously,
so you did have to pay a lot of attention to that process.
Later on,
a couple of years later,
you drive with your Basal Ganglia.
You can probably,
you know,
get up in the morning half asleep and get yourself to work in your car.
I'm not suggesting that's a good idea.
I'm just saying you probably do a lot of things while you drive.
People talk on the phone,
people talk to the person sitting next to them.
People eat on the car,
people put on makeup in the car,
people text while driving.
And you know,
that's leads to a lot of mistakes.
But you can get from a to B without even noticing what you did because it's in
your basal Ganglia.
The brain is a lazy couch potato and likes to make things easy for it.
Whatever you do with the prefrontal cortex takes up a lot of energy.
There's something that psychologists call ego depletion or decision fatigue.
After a long day of heavy thinking and paying attention to things,
you're just done with it,
right?
You don't want to think anymore.
You just want to watch Netflix or something like this.
You don't,
you don't.
You have used up all your willpower at the end of a long day.
So the prefrontal cortex is not an unlimited resource.
It's an research that gets depleted easily,
that gets distracted easily,
and that gets run over by the parts of the brain very easily.
Okay?
So today I just wanted you to not just talk about the prefrontal Cortex,
but to make you experience how easily it gets knocked up.
So if you want to be successful in life and if you want to be successful at your
jobs and high performing,
you need to find ways to make the prefrontal cortex functioning properly.
And there's three things we need in order to put,
you know,
in order to make our prefrontal cortex happy.
And these are the things I would like to show you today.
Are you ready for that?
Okay.
So here it goes.
If this performance,
and I don't mean you know how much money you make or if other people think
you're smart or you know,
things like that,
I'm thinking about how high performing is your individual prefontal cortex at
this given moment.
Okay?
So this is measuring performance of your prefrontal cortex over here and here we
have stress level,
okay?
Basically here you would say you were in a coma,
sleep on over here,
you would be close to a panic attack.
And in between there's many different circumstances and situations you could be
in.
So usually let's say somebody here calls you up and says,
you know,
we have this new initiative at Google.
We don't know yet if we're going to go through with it.
It's just a new idea.
Maybe next year we're going to have a meeting about this.
While we don't know yet to scoring to sponsor it.
So could you please put together some PowerPoint presentation for this?
And some ideas
doesn't sound very good,
does it?
So you're just going to sit at your desk and you're probably going to clean up
your desk and procrastinate and do other things,
but your highest performance will not be on this job.
This is true for all kinds of routine jobs such as doing your expenses or
checking your emails.
You can do a lot of things just with your Basal Ganglia,
right?
You,
we'll just go through the motions.
No effort required and the performance of your prefrontal cortex will be very
low.
So now let's imagine that you're supposed to give a presentation in front of
your CEO.
I know you have your Christmas party tonight and you can now receive an email
this very moment telling you,
why don't you give a spontaneous speech tonight presenting,
you know,
your latest results at work.
We'd love to hear more about this.
It should be five to 10 minutes and you know,
just prepare something really fun and energizing for people,
engage them,
and afterwards we're going to write you and this will influence the bonus you
get.
Okay?
Something like this there.
Chances are that your performance is good to be down here because you might be
so sweating and terrified.
Everybody's watching you all eyes on you,
okay?
And then maybe right before your honor on it,
you realize that all of your numbers are wrong or that you know something is not
working out with your presentation when we are under an extreme stress,
okay?
When we experiencing stress,
our prefrontal cortex shuts down.
This is what happens.
Your brain will go into fight,
flight,
or freeze,
and this will lead to the fact that our brain just shuts down.
Not all parts of the brain,
but the prefontal cortex will shut down because every illusionary,
from an evolutionary perspective,
if you have to fight a bear in the forest,
you wouldn't want to think of 10 different creative solutions of how to fight a
bear.
You can either fight or flight or freeze and hide under a Bush or something like
that,
so under stress,
the prefrontal cortex shuts down.
When my very bored,
our prefrontal cortex does not feel motivated to work,
and then in both cases it's your basal Ganglia are doing the job when way bored.
We just go and click it to our habits.
We do the things we always do.
We go through the motions.
Other people might even think you're performing well because if you have good
habits,
then you can go through a lot in life just with your Basal Ganglia,
right?
To all depends on what kind of training you had and what's in there.
If you're very stressed,
your brain will also rely on your basal Ganglia because your prefrontal cortex
does not work properly anymore.
Then you also have to rely on instincts.
That's why,
and professor professions like fire fighting and the police and medical doctors
who work in emergencies,
they train people a lot.
Psychologists call this overtraining overlearning because they want to make sure
that people have the right kind of actions.
Stuart and the Basal Ganglia.
So in the military for example,
you train how to pull the trigger 100 million times so that when the emergency
situation comes up and your prefrontal cortex shuts down,
you know exactly what to do and you make the decision within milliseconds
because the prefrontal cortex is slow,
but your basal Ganglia are quick and their work without you not even noticing,
they just go on autopilot.
Okay,
but this is where you want to be with your prefrontal Cortex,
right?
If you want to be innovative,
if you want to come up with new ideas,
if you want to create something new and exciting and your company,
you have to engage your prefrontal cortex.
As you can see,
there's an inverse correlation between stress level and performance.
If there's too little stress,
you will just do business as usual.
People might even go into bore out.
People love what you do.
You might get compliments for your work,
but it's a bit boring and irrelevant and you just do it,
but it's,
you know,
nobody cares about your work.
And over here you might have a situation with too many deadlines,
too many people wanting stuff from you,
bad bosses who you know follow after you and give you bad feedback.
All of the time.
Things like this can really wear down your prefrontal cortex.
So how can you get up here?
Okay.
When we reached peak performance,
we lose concept of time.
If you ever had a moment at your work or in your free time when you really were
performing at your best,
it could be in sports,
it could be music,
it could be an arts,
it could even be at your job.
You lose the concept of time.
You're fully present here now and you love what you do.
Usually this is associated with joyful.
It's a joyful experience.
Research shows also that when we are in this state of mind,
we are five times as productive five times as productive.
That's a lot.
You could save a lot of time if you know how to get there whenever you want it,
whenever you need it.
Rather than spending most of your time here or here for your most strategic
task,
for your most important decisions,
for the things that truly matter,
you should know how to get here and there are three things you need,
and I call them fun,
fear
and focus.
Why should you have fun at work?
Aren't you paid to work?
You know it shouldn't that be what you receive for your hard work?
Isn't that enough?
Research shows that when people have fun at work and neurotransmitter called
dopamine is released in your brain.
I will write it here.
For those of you who want to remember that,
so you have the dopamine,
okay?
And the Delta mean,
it's a real brain booster.
Dopamine is a neurotransmitter that links into the reward system of your brain
and will make you think faster.
It will make you learn faster and it will make this a very joyful experience.
If you think about it.
It's not by coincidence that most famous people and who excel in some area
really love what they do.
Because when you're really good at something than dopamine is released and it
makes it even better.
So if you want to have more fun at work,
this is not just about having free food and all of the gadgets you enjoy here at
Google of the after Work Party kind fun you're going to have tonight.
It's more about do you truly love what you do,
reo really good at what you're doing,
you know,
fun related to the task that you perform every day.
So my advice to you would be to find a job where you can be really the best in
class,
not something where you're kind of doing okay,
ish six something where your talents can shine and then you will get burst of
dopamine that will help your brain to perform much better.
Other ways to get more dopamine are to,
for example,
work with surprise and novelty.
Every time we get surprised,
our brain releases still Permian.
Every time something new happens,
our brain reacts by eliciting dopamine.
So that little exercise we did hear a few minutes ago,
I also did this in order to get you out of a Rut,
you come to listen to a talk,
but I wanted you to also do something you didn't expect to be doing because this
will give everybody a burst of dopamine and it will make your retained better.
What I tell you today,
jokes are a good way to get the dopamine burst.
When people love the,
when people laugh,
the brain release a stove.
I mean,
so if you want people to learn well and to perform well at work,
it might pay off to have somebody really funny at the team.
Maybe somebody's not really high performing person,
not so
I'm serious,
funny people boost everybody's performance.
So you know,
if you have this fellow who's not adding much value but making jokes,
keep that guy on the team
from a brain perspective,
laughs really boosts performance.
So that's the fun.
The second thing is the fear.
I don't know if you have experienced that,
but I have a friend and she went to a Bob Dylan concert and what happened is
that she hated it.
Why did she hate it?
Because he was playing new songs she never heard before.
She wanted to hear the songs of she knew and love to sing along and instead he
was going totally experimental on stage and she said,
I didn't know the stuff he was singing.
It was okay.
Why did Bob Dylan do this?
He was upsetting his audience.
Nobody loved the concert.
People hated it.
Well,
otherwise I guess he would have been bored to death.
If you're Bob Dylan and you've been doing the same thing for 40 years,
you don't want to play the same songs.
It goes out of your ears.
Your ears will explode if you hear that song one more time.
I Dunno,
I'm not Bob Dylan,
but I guess that's what's good.
What was going on in his mind.
You need to try new things.
You need to push the boundaries.
Most people,
when you ask them how can you reach best performance,
they say this happens when the challenge meets your skillset.
No,
that's not true.
This happens when the challenge exceeds your skill set.
You need to be slightly over challenged.
Okay?
Find a job you really love and then push yourself to the boundaries.
Get over the tub,
do things that are a bit too difficult for you.
Do things that are a bit scary.
If you're never scared at your job,
something's wrong with you.
You need to be sometimes a bit nervous.
You need to try new things.
You need to experiment.
If you're always staying in your comfort zone,
your brain would react by going into your basal Ganglia.
Because when we have a slight level of fear,
Oh our brain releases a substance called noradrenaline and noradrenaline is a
positive stress hormones.
Okay?
Nor good.
Nolan might not be the prettiest flip chart you guys have seen.
But um,
so here it is for those of you who want to write it down.
So you need the Dopa mean,
but you also need the Noradrenalin when there's no challenge,
when there's no deadline.
When nobody cares about what you're doing,
you will underperform.
You will go into Basal Ganglia mode.
So push yourself.
If you find yourself too comfortable in your role,
you might want to quit your job or go on a job rotation or try something new.
If you're getting too comfortable,
you will go into bore out and your brain will think,
why should I engage my prefrontal cortex?
It costs me a lot of energy and attention to engage my prefrontal cortex.
The brain will only do it when it's really necessary and if there is no
challenge,
if there's snow fear,
your brain will not go through all of this effort.
So you need to be slightly over challenged to achieve that.
Okay?
Yes.
A question and he got dinged.
A fear and distress.
Well,
I'm not an expert in this issue at all,
but um,
that's uh,
Auriemma um,
is it,
is it good one when we are a bit nervous or with fear,
but easy to associated also with cortisol,
like it happens at the same time an easy because I've earned that cortisol is
not that good for your performance.
So then I would like to know your opinion about that.
Yeah,
cortisol is also helpful,
but it's not a good thing.
Cortisol is a negative stress hormone.
So what happens with cortisol is that if you have that over a longer period of
time and your body,
your will go into burnout or part of your brain called the Amygdala,
which is processing negative information will grow.
Your prefrontal cortex will shrink.
Your hippocampus for learning will shrink as well.
So Cortisol has a very damaging impact on our brain,
but when it's cortisol released,
cortisol is released.
When,
um,
there's chronic stress over a longer period of time.
So let's say you have an awful boss who treats you badly.
If you live in a relationship,
if you go to your job every morning and you feel that you hate it,
that will give you a level of cortisol.
When you feel so overstressed that you can sleep anymore,
it's the cortisol hindering you to,
to go to sleep,
nor adrenaline gives you positive push.
Okay?
So it gives you a kick.
Cortisol will slow things down for you.
So this is the matter of whether it's a short term stress.
Here I'm speaking about short term stress,
which is good,
or whether it's a long term stress.
And then the mom,
number one protection factor for cortisol is actually autonomy.
If you think about it,
big bosses in large organizations,
they work many hours,
but they're not as stressed as the people at the bottom who may be work nine to
five because when we can influence the situation,
that's when our brain makes sense of the situation.
It does matter whether you work up to 3:00 AM because your boss told you to do
that or whether you work up to 3:00 AM because it's your company and you chose
to do that.
If you feel that it's this a purpose associated with it.
So if you want to avoid cortisol,
try to take as much control of the situation as you can rather than being a
victim,
go into more active role to to fight the situation.
Okay,
so that's the noradrenaline and the fear part.
What about focus?
Imagine some,
you know,
some athlete in the middle of a match like Johnny Saxton or imagined Serena
Williams playing a tennis match,
and then in the middle of the match,
she's pulling out her cell phone.
She says,
I just need to take the call,
hold on a moment or need to check my emails.
People would hate that.
Their fence would be appalled.
People would be shocked.
But in the business world,
that's how people behave all the time.
Constantly.
People are multitasking.
People are constantly checking their emails.
People are hardly ever focused,
right?
And research shows that when we multitask,
we make 50% more mistakes and we take 50% longer to complete the task.
Research also shows that today's teenagers have the attention span shorter than
the one of an average goldfish.
Attention span is going down.
Our brains are plastic.
We're adapting to new situations,
and if you're constantly multitasking,
you're not getting better at it.
Your attention span is actually going down because your brain says,
I never need focused prolonged attention.
Right?
I never needed it.
So why should I develop that skill?
But it's impossible to reach peak performance.
If you're not fully focused,
because when you're fully focused and present in the moment,
your brain will release a substance called Acetylcholine.
Let me write it down here for you.
As we saw in the little exercise we did in the group this morning,
you're really had to focus on keeping the seven out of the game,
right?
You really had to focus on these complex calculations.
Your prefrontal cortex will only work when you're fully focused.
It requires attention.
It's impossible to get into flow if you're not focused.
So what should you do about it?
I mean,
there's many ways to go.
One of them is,
for example,
to eliminate distractions from the onset because our prefrontal cortex is a
limited resource.
If you are going to spend all of your energy suppressing the urge to check your
phone,
let's say it's on your desk while you work on something and then you just read a
book that told you that multitasking is bad and then you decided to check it
less,
you always got to look at it and think,
no,
okay,
I check it later.
Get rid of it.
Okay,
put it somewhere else.
I,
I know that many executives are no doing what is called a meeting of one.
When we get in a meeting with other people,
we always schedule time.
We turn off the phone,
we don't check.
You know,
we really focus on that meeting,
but you should be just as
critical,
rigorous when you have a meeting with yourself.
If you really have to put an important presentation together,
if you're really have to solve an important question,
take some time.
Block your door.
Don't let people walk in on you.
You know,
I don't know if you have an open office policy or something like this.
Put something in front of your door so that nobody can get in.
It's nice to be social,
but research shows that when people have too much open office spaces,
collaboration,
communication actually decreases.
You think it would go up,
but it actually goes down because people are hiding because it's impossible to
focus if you constantly have your colleagues in your,
so find a way to truly focus on your work.
But I,
I would like to let you in on a little secret.
Most books will tell you that,
you know,
eliminating distraction is the right way to improve focus.
Or that you should go to a mindfulness training course and learn meditation and
do yoga,
something to train up your inherent ability to focus.
That's good,
but it's not really working because people know that multitasking is bad and
they keep doing it anyhow.
Why do they keep doing it anyhow?
Because we're addicted to our phones.
If you think about it,
every time you get a new email or something happens or social media,
your brain thinks,
oh,
there could be something new and relevant going on.
I need to check that out.
And then you get a burst of dopamine and you get a burst of noradrenaline
because there could be something relevant for you.
And when we are bored at work and the less tired and a bit,
you know,
not fully motivated,
you might just as well pick up your phone to see if something new is going on in
order to get a quick burst of dopamine or when you're very stressed and you want
to escape from that situation,
your phone could be an escape strategy from the,
rather than focusing on what's going on around you,
you focus on your phone and what happens is that every time and your email comes
up or something new happens,
you get these bursts of dopamine and they link into the reward circuits in your
brain and you get addicted to it and you need more and more and more.
As you can see in teenagers,
Druck use has gone down,
but phone use has gone up,
so it's a new drug basically in the fray in the brain,
I'm multitasking and the use of mobile devices is treated like an addiction.
If you look at people's brain while they're looking at the phone,
it's like a brain in love or Brighton on drugs.
So I want to invite you to create a work environment that is more fun and where
you have the right level of fear and then focus will come naturally.
Pay attention to that.
You will see that these things are correlated to each other.
When you have fun at work and when there's truly something at stake,
when it's challenging,
your focus will be the I immediately yes,
they,
they uh,
had a session with executives.
They were walking on glass.
We first wanted to do a fire walk,
but then the university building wouldn't allow that.
So then we did a glass walk on real it,
you know,
it was 70 bottles of glass shattered,
70 bottles of wine shattered on the floor and people were walking over it
barefoot.
Nobody was multitasking while doing that.
Everybody was focused.
Trust me,
I've seen people,
everybody was really paying attention while walking because you don't want to
hurt yourself.
So you have a certain level of fear.
And it was kind of fun because it was new and unexpected,
not something you do every day.
Right?
Let's walk on glass today.
So people had fun,
people had fear,
and everybody was focused.
We didn't even have to tell people to focus.
Focus just happened.
So if you find yourself having trouble with focus,
improve the level of fun,
improve the level of fear and it will come naturally.
Thank you.
[inaudible] you have
Christians,
so you're kind of talking a lot about like delaying or postponing gratification.
Um,
what are some of the more specific things that people could do to try and be
better at that?
To delay gratification.
Yeah.
Cause that seems,
what's your kind of thesis is there?
Yeah.
Well find something you truly love and practice it.
Research shows that people like musicians who have to practice a lot to get
better,
they have a better executive control because let's say if you spend all of your
day playing video games,
you get an instant reward all of the time.
You know,
you just pushed some button and then it's Whoa,
you know,
something happened.
I kind of disagree with that,
honestly.
Yes.
Like in many computer games,
you don't just mindlessly mash on buttons.
You actually have to think about your skillset,
develop yourself.
You have to train,
you have to look at other people's,
how they strategized a lot of things and actually a lot of research recently has
been showing that like computer games happening,
increasing one's ability to focus and train oneself and getting in many states
of flow,
which is
what'd y'all talk about in the game,
but not necessarily outside the game,
but you can apply it elsewhere.
Yeah,
but I think you get more instant reward and the video game that if you do
practicing the cello,
definitely.
Yeah,
that I agree.
Right.
I agree with you that in the moment when you play the video game,
you are in flow.
You have the fun,
you have the fear,
you have the folk was for sure,
but if you do things that give you no gratification in the beginning,
such as learning to play an instrument or reading long books with more than a
hundred pages,
right,
then what happens is that your brain will get used to not get everything right
away,
but a lot of it has to do with parenting.
If your parents brought you up to work for things,
then you probably will continue to do that later in life as well.
So when you have kids you should be thinking about not spoiling them too much or
they will not have that ability to delay gratification.
And then you have what we see today that many millennials are having suicidal
thoughts and are very unhappy because they always got everything from their
parents than ever had to work to get anything.
Okay,
so you're talking about um,
the correlation between performance and stress.
So if you were to look at it in a perspective of time as well,
because for me,
the dopamine and noradrenaline and all of the fun fear and focus teams to be a
little bit more short term side true or how like how long can you keep going?
Like that
short term thing,
you cannot be all day and flow and you shouldn't be all day and slow.
Because if,
think about it when your brain releases dopamine and noradrenaline
Acetylcholine,
it gives your brain a quick burst but then it vanished it quickly.
If you think about negative stress hormones such as cortisol,
the hit to your body and they can stay forever.
Let's say you know I give you a positive and give you 10 things to think about
it.
Say you did great on this and this and this and this and this and this and great
job at this and great and great hooray.
And they'll say you have one little area for improvement,
one little thing to work on.
That's the one you're going to remember.
We are wired to focus on negative things.
Okay,
so what this means is that this is a short term thing.
You should use that if you want to get something really important done and then
it's okay to spend the rest of the day.
Sometimes under challenged,
sometimes over challenged.
This is something you should use for your most important moments.
If you think about athletes,
they spent a week training and recovering and then they're just have a one hour
match.
You need that for that one hour match and afterwards your brain will be
depleted.
What do you see is that when your brain will is still pumping?
When all of that dopamine is used up,
you feel kind of like exhausted.
So it's a short term thing.
So,
uh,
most of us don't truly have their offices here.
It's a plan.
And basically if you want to disconnect,
what about for instance,
listening to the music and,
and specific music more like Costco.
I didn't get to your questions,
so you would wish to this.
If you want to be skull neck guitar does listening to the music,
uh,
help that orange stripe.
So if you want to focus whether it's good to listen to music,
well for some people it's good and for others there's,
it's not research shows that this is highly individual.
It seems that a little bit of background noise.
It's good if you want to be creative here.
I've been here,
we've been speaking about the flow state and then music can be good if it's not
disrupting you,
if it helps you to get,
if it's quieter than the more quiet than the people around you.
But if you,
for example,
want to be a bit creative and if you're designing things and if you're working
in a more artistic way of working,
it could be okay to have an office that is like Starbucks,
you know,
with lots of people running around because then these distractions will give
your brain some impact to pack,
to make connections that you haven't made before.
So the answer is for some people it's good and for some jobs it's good with you
really have to just concentrate and focus.
And if you're working more artistically it's actually okay to be a bit more
distracted.
Thank you so much for the,
for the talk.
Have a question.
When do you provide these talks or the courses like the walking on glass?
Um,
they're probably tailored to the group but they'd probably run from your own BSG
as well because you do it so often.
What do you do to create the final few and focus for yourself?
That's a really good question.
Actually.
The little experiment here,
we did with the,
with the standing up.
I've only done this once before.
I always create new stuff for myself and usually,
you know,
I've just changed it now.
I made it about the prefrontal cortex and the Basal Ganglia.
I always taken other brain parts.
You know,
I changed my presentations,
I adapt them.
I try to also,
for me,
well,
the fun for me is the purpose because I see that people get the benefit for what
I'm doing.
So if people tell me,
or this was really helpful and write to me a year later,
then this for me adds value to my life,
to what I'm doing.
The fear is,
you know,
I mean public failure,
I could be here on stage making a mess and you know,
somebody asks very smart questions and I could be standing here,
you know,
like in full idiot,
this can happen,
right?
And then your reputation is kind of ruined.
This will be filmed.
So there's always a level of fear and focus.
MMM.
Once I have the fun and the fear comes,
but a mix things up and what as it happens for me,
my engagements get bigger.
I get more speeches with more people there.
More than thousands,
you know,
when they started out with small groups.
And now I get this sometimes big things where I have to design something new.
Yeah.
Thank you very much.
Thank you for all your questions.
Thank you for Federica for this great talk.
And I think there is no doubt that we need to train our bodies,
but our brain is well,
and now we'll have an instruction.
Uh,
thank you so much.
Thank you.
[inaudible].